NICK FOLIGNO PIVOTS.
THOSE ARE 2 ON ONE
WIG --
HENRI JOKIHARJU LONG
WRIST SHOT,KREBS
TRENT FREDERIC.
AND THEY'RE
DOING A NICE JOB ON
THE ELBOW.
CAUSING A PROBLEM FOR
STAT.
USK ON, THE
DOORSTEP TIP, AND
BERGERON CLEANS IT UP!
BUT THEN THEY STAYED
RIGHT THERE WITH
DEBRUSK.
FINALLY, BERGERON, ON
THE LAST DRIVE,BERGERT
THE PUCKS, KEEP THEM
ALIVE.
BERGERON DID THE JOB>S
DETERMINED THAT THEGO.
RCE FOR
WHAT WE ARE ABOUT TO
SEE HERE, AND .TAYLORE
PERFECT PAST, AFTER>>L
IN THE ATTACKING
ZONE.
>> AFTER REVIEWING
THE
DANGLES A PENALTY
KILLER, RIGHT THERE,
GETS TO THE MIDDLE OF
A REDIRECT, A STOP ON
THE ICE BY TOKARSKI.
E
TAYLOR HALL SWITCH?
>> JACK: ROUTE
DOWN THE  FIRING ON A
SHOT.
LOOK AT THOSE PLAY BY
MARCHAND.
.
SAVED.
MARCHAND